[Music]
having a personal radio speaker facing
away from you
missed that one the last time so thank
goodness for the previously on segment
spoiler logos or splogos if you will as
in yes marvel continues to use a full 35
seconds each episode to participate in a
masturbatory cacophony of visuals below
going
separate beds without a shared
nightstand between them it's almost like
the show needs to space empty for a bed
combining joke later
are you using your powers to turn on the
light better question why haven't we
blocked the light streaming into the
window that's forced me to wear an eye
pillow
one to die yes dear
get the light pulling the blankets all
the way over your head to have sex
since when do you need more than one
person at a time under there see the
problem with this is that it probably
means something else
this isn't a simple star and moon moment
this is a hint to a deeper lore that
only the bravest of marvel nerds will
know
i wanna know too i don't wanna google
every damn thing
like this or this or this or this
i continue to be bewitched by how
perfectly these episodes imitate the
opening titles of the era it's set in
but i can't just be taking sins off
willy-nilly so
um scene does not contain an elizabeth
montgomery nosewiggle
letting the water run after you're out
of the shower fred and linda are
building a moat in a fully functioning
portcullis and no one even knows why
but then the show never lets us see fred
and linda's moat in portcullis
oh was that a metaphor
ruining the mystery of magic
the way these first episodes layer in
the mystery while creating such a
perfect recreation of the sitcoms of the
past is not only quite a balancing act
to pull off it's honestly a pretty bold
and strange choice
props to marvel for not taking the weird
out of comic book storytelling
take your sin back you senor scratchy
just
loves the stage he played baby jesus in
last year's christmas pageant
isn't having a rabbit play jesus just a
hair sacrilegious
also naming your rabbit senor scratchy
dottie is the key to everything in this
town
noted and so help me if this doesn't
turn out to be true and i'm obsessing
over far too many details
i will never take this sin back just
mind your p's and q's and you're going
to do
just fine i was today years old when i
realized ps and q's stands for
pleases and thank yous and this is a sin
for an educational system that failed me
leaving your baseball bat outside how
are you going to defend yourself from a
burglar now
i'm sorry dotty i didn't ask about the
chairs so you better not ask me if you
can share any committees in the future
over selling your puns i love seat based
puns too but you gotta couch that stuff
in subtly to cushion the blow
anything else is just lazy boy devil's
in the details bev
like the t-glass that was clearly on the
table behind bev but when she walks away
from the table it's missing
pardon me is this a neighborhood watch
meeting if it is and
it is it shouldn't be a meeting where
nearly 10 people are discussing town
events should not be happening in the
middle of a library where silence is
expected
move that meeting to a private room no
vision new business
actually means another round of danish
it does not
in any context mean this okay for us to
stick a big red
oh well hold on there a second did you
hear the man he doesn't eat food but
then he clarified and then the laugh
track laughed
and this is a dumb thing to say well my
understanding is that it's purely for
mastication
oh no i don't do that confusing
mastication with masturbation which
honestly leads to very uncomfortable
sexual experiences
so i've heard this gum looks way too
happy to have been chewed up and
swallowed why are you so happy big red
why
okay i'm digging the mystery i really am
but when do we start getting some
answers
oh i know i'll just binge the rest of
the season now so i can get some relief
let's see where is this on disney plus
is it wait is this not
no
also no wait how does a housewife get a
blood stain out of white linen
by doing it herself forgetting the the
same way she climax is part of the joke
stretch watch bands mixed with arm hair
ouch
oh like stroker from the comics and it
says hydra
and it's set to 242 and the shape of the
four looks like a knife
and it says 1000 meters and i for sure
know what all of this means but i
totally don't want to spoil it for you
guys
trucker but also doesn't the um change
the u to more of a
u sound so shouldn't this be like
streaker
or something my point is you can't add
fancy dots to you and not change the
pronunciation
vision's intestinal issues are far worse
than expected his gears have swapped
sides from earlier
and for our final act i give you
wanda and vision roll commercials
whoa that's never happened before i
didn't even know i had those powers um
yeah anyway they said the title of the
show so uh do the thing
i was just playing with his shoes
[Laughter]
paul bettany is absolutely slaying this
illusion
ah master of enigma allow me
this piano is clearly still
three-dimensional after she does her
finger wiggle
even though later we see it's not is
this god
this is this your card's on for some
time i'm doing it
sharita from donnie darko would be
excellent at tv sins
what's in the box what's in the box
i swear to the tv gods if they open that
box and pepper potts comes out i'm
giving back
every sin gladly what is going on with
you
i have no idea i've been feeling weirdy
all day
except he knows exactly what happened he
wasn't asleep when he swallowed the gum
he searched his mouth for it immediately
it wasn't so hard to fit in after all
title of my
sex tape
no hijacking the remote
oh no not the beast not the beast
did you know that we create monthly
exclusive videos for our city club
members bonus outtakes
i don't know peter meth is a hell of a
drug extra sins videos
strange things are afoot at the circle k
and even member chosen sin commentaries
i love this
i love this this kind of of a sin
because it's just
it's so silly pick our next video and
see the exclusives at patreon.com
cinemasins or click the link in the
description below spiderman is not a
parade you do not need to stop traffic
for spiders
all of this is for the children for the
children
you know for kids and you both have
severe psychological problems and i see
i'm i'm i'm
i'm the nice one here how is anybody
doing this sober
just one more drink i'll cut off your
cats with a knife you [ __ ]
i too have some top secret gossip to
share i'm
i'm taking it in my butt i can't help
but wonder if you and i haven't gotten
off on the wrong foot
dottie and i would like to correct that
if i can
and how would you do that look daddy i
like you
like i like you pop quiz wanda
there's a bomb on a bus once the bus
goes 50 miles an hour
the bomb is armed